well I think what my friend Angelina  does everything she does is amazing she  she's just flown in from Australia so  she can be here tonight and then she'll  fly right back where she's directing a  film about one of our last great  generation of heroes of world war ii  that hero is here at her table tonight  mr. Lou Zamperini  the other night I was watching another  movie that Angie directed and wrote in  the Land of Blood and Honey it was a  very moving piece it's a just a stunning  film to watch don't don't miss it but  after I watched it I got thinking I she  have time to do all of this she acts in  many pictures now she writes and directs  and she has a large family about 20 I  think it last counted and she has to  keep that smile on Brad's face  I have to take my hat off to her  Angelina I'm so happy to be here to  celebrate you tonight as you receive the  Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award you  certainly deserve